[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster unconstant in kissin and
this is the show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people and a fascinating guest we have
for you today he's a science writer
historian of science he's the founder of
the skeptic Society the editor-in-chief
of the skeptic magazine he's very
skeptical basically is what I'm saying
Michael Shermer welcome to trigonometry
thanks for having me and I'll try not to
get it triggered for this our ideas that
you trigger people and with our help so
that's what we're trying to work - well
apparently apparently I I do sometimes
trigger people on the far left and and
far right which means I'm doing my job
that's exactly what we do on the show
those are two groups of people we have
triggered a lot recently and I'm sure
we'll do that more of that together but
before we get into it just for anyone
who doesn't know who you I most people
will do but for anyone who doesn't just
tell everybody who are you what is your
journey through life how do you happen
to be sitting here talking to us
well the main trigger as it were as my
new book giving the devil is do my
latest book my 13th book actually my
life's work really involves trying to
understand what truth is that is how do
we get to the truth we want to know
what's true not not just what I want to
be true but what's actually true
empirically true using empirical science
and and reason and rationality and
critical thinking and that's the core of
skepticism is you start off assuming
that the claim is not true until proven
otherwise because most of us most of the
time get things wrong and so my argument
for free speech in giving the devil
who's due is that the devil is whoever
disagrees with you or that you disagree
with that you don't like or you consider
to be you know uttering hate speech or
whatever and the reason they should be
given their due is because you would
want that for yourself when you are in
the position pushing back against the
mainstream or challenging the accepted
dogma and you get silenced because
you've signed off on
on seeing others that that's dangerous
so you know the and again the quorum is
is that we're much of the time and the
only way to find out if you're wrong is
to talk to other people
so with skeptic magazine we we're not
afraid to talk buddy you know I we've
done issues on Holocaust denial and
creationism and climate denial and
vaccine aisle and you know I'll talk to
anybody and and ask them you know what
is it you believe and why and just just
lay it out for me and and we'll publish
those we'll publish your very words and
then you know then we'll address them
now I'm not afraid to debunk them as
well but I still think they should be
given their due in the sense that none
of us can get it right all the time so
we have to listen to you know dissenting
voices just in case well I guess one of
the most difficult issues that's been
brought up and you spend a lot of time
in the book talking about free speech
it's it's the first and most probably
one of the more significant portions of
it but one of the difficulties that the
pandemic has brought up I don't know if
you followed this case in the UK where
we had a well known conspiracy theorist
David Icke who gave an interview about
how the 5g masks are causing the corona
virus and soon afterwards there was a
spate of arson attacks against 5g mass
right and of YouTube and that video then
he went and did another interview and a
platform bla bla bla bla bla and I think
that's one of probably the most
difficult cases where you think well is
this personal speech causing destruction
of property etc what where do you stand
on something like that because I don't
know if I've still worked out what my
position on that is yeah I know that
case I watched that interview and then I
was on Bryan Rosa's London real show to
talk about it and I I think even someone
is kind of far out there or nuttier or
fringy as as David Icke should be given
his due now when I say that I don't mean
we're obligated to put him on every show
so he has his voice it's up to him to to
find a platform for his his conspiracy
theories and if somebody takes
I'm up on him fine don't you don't sense
for that and you know he's not again
he's not completely crazy you know if
you listen to him he's obviously fairly
smart particularly man you know but his
chain of reasoning leads them down you
know some you know off the rails down
some crazy pathways where he ends up
with the lizard aliens running the world
or or you know the 5g towers now is are
his words responsible for somebody
firebombing a tower I would say that
it's a bit of a reach that is to say
people that would do something like that
if you point out to them where David
Icke was wrong they're not likely to be
changing their mind anyway technology I
use is with the you know the famous
story about the spirit c-3 about Hillary
Clinton running pedophile ring out of a
pizzeria you know before the 2016
election I mean this is as crazy as it
gets and some guy showed up to this
pizzeria with a gun you know and it's
only no one was hurt but you know people
acting on like that and people that
believe that my correcting them on you
know Hillary's not running a pedophile
ring a pizzeria they're not you know
they're not gonna change their mind
about Hillary on this and they're likely
to do something crazy anyway because
that's that particular conspiracy theory
is not why they're agitated why not why
they're not not why they're out there
doing their things like that in any case
the moment you set up a gatekeeper that
says like like apparently Google /
YouTube is doing either algorithms or
actual people sitting there watching
videos and making the decision are we
gonna allow this or not then you're down
the pathway of expanding that category
include more and more things that are
kind of moderate you know kind of you
know within the kind of the Overton
Window as it's called of discussable
subjects that category gets bigger and
then and then censorship expands and
then more and more of us or self
censoring or afraid to say what we think
because we might be cancelled or
censored or kicked off YouTube or
Twitter Instagram or whatever and that's
a dangerous path to go so that's why I'm
paid
one of the book I talk about the 1919
decisions over a century ago now of
schenck versus the United States
Charles Schenk was the head of the
Socialist Party in Philadelphia and he
was distributing pamphlets flyers to
draft age men to protest the draft he
said it was unconstitutional the 13th
14th amendment protects you from slavery
and and guarantee your bodily autonomy
and the draft is basically saying the
government can take my body and send me
off to war to die if it wants and that's
a kind of a form of slavery now that's a
debatable point but that's not the point
that I'm making is that just saying that
whether there's a criminal act an act of
treason at the time and that's when
Oliver Wendell Holmes made his famous
decision in which he included that
phrase a clear and present danger that
was the equivalent of shouting fire in a
theater
all shouting fire theater well you know
oh decades more and more thing I put
into that bin of clear and present
danger such to the point where anybody
uh Turing any criticism criticism of the
government could be considered a clear
and present danger so we gotta shut this
guy up and that's where you end up with
you know about the seventies you end up
with the language police and political
correctness and you know every utterance
could be considered a clear and present
danger to somebody somewhere and then
you know by the 90s and early 2000s you
end up with well to paraphrase you the
title of your podcast you know people
that are triggered by the tiniest little
things like the paroxysm at Yale over
Halloween costumes you know where
Nicholas Christakis and his wife is you
know sent that email out saying you know
we're not going to tell you what kind of
costumes are wearing Halloween you're
adults you know and and for this they
were you know totally just shattered
like no you're like our parents you have
to tell us what to do this is a complete
reversal the way things used to be right
well it's quite a journey my own before
Francis jump in let me just follow up
because just to stick with the David
Icke thing just for a moment let I'm
just trying to work it through in my
head like I said I don't know what I
think and I'm trying to work it out
which is I think the spirit in which you
engage with
yeah alright so if david icke is right
now i don't think he is but if he's
right that 5g masts are responsible for
at this point of time recording three
hundred and fifty thousand deaths around
the world would would I not be
reasonable in going out and burning down
a 5g mast I mean would that not be the
right response and therefore is his
making that argument not causing me to
think potentially I should do this yeah
well it's already illegal to do that to
do commit violence against other people
to destroy property to burgle and and
although those are already crimes so
anybody doing that for whatever reason
it's still wrong it's illegal and
immoral period I mean if you really
believed it then the way to do it would
it be to address the government to look
into the matter or curtail the
activities of telecommunications
companies regulate the
telecommunications companies I mean the
government already does this a lot
I mean you we don't have to nudge the
government to be more regulatory the
regulatory state is massive right so
there's already an apparatus in place to
address those kinds of problems if there
was evidence for it and clearly there
isn't because if there was the
government would be all over it this is
what government regulators love to do
they love to nose around in private
companies and regulate them so it's not
like that you know that that isn't in
place already so I'm really not worried
about that but let's do say why it's
wrong I mean 5g is just an extension of
4G extension of 3G and so on all the way
back to the 90s and the Motorola flip
phone that you held up to your ear and
the fears back then that this was
causing brain tumors right yeah and
these were just cancer clusters you know
you throw a bunch of pennies up in the
air and they land on the ground they're
not perfectly spaced out they're
clustering and and this is true of
everything in life including cancer
cases they're clustered so you're going
to get clustering of people that use a
lot of cellphones and people that have
brain tumors just randomly and that's
all it was and and so those kinds of
conspiracies have always been around as
well as you know by the way Bill Gates
you know
gays have been trying to con world since
the nineties and of course he wasn't
trying to conquer the world and software
but that's a different thing than what
the good thing you know and I'm now
predicting that Bezos will replace Bill
Gates as Voldemort is the evil Darth
Vader because you know he's now poised
to become the first trillionaire in
history so he will be a target you know
and that tells us what's really going on
here these are you know fear of the
unknown fear of the invisible
you know the virus is invisible the you
know it electromagnetic radiation coming
from the 5g South hours is invisible
nuclear power is invisible people fear
things that have effects that are
powerful that they can't see smell taste
touch and the virus is essentially
invisible without a high-powered
microscope
you know we had never seen a virus so
you know that tells us something about
human psychology what is your argument
to the people who to those people say
look these companies run a small
emergency the the world hasn't seen this
type of thing for at least a hundred
years companies and in particular
organizations need to be responsible in
these are very very fractious times and
putting out an interview like the David
Icke one is quite frankly irresponsible
and could lead to some very serious
consequences and in times like this we
need greater restriction yeah I would
say to that because I think you're
referring to Brian Rose who did that had
David Icke on I I would not have David
Icke on my podcast because I would feel
that I'm giving him a platform perhaps
he doesn't deserve I would discuss him I
would make me write articles about him
or addressed his claims which I just did
but that's you know that's just me you
know Brian roses is his own man he can
do what he wants and of course Google is
a private company and it consents or in
which it did you know I mean YouTube in
this case alphabet parent company of
Google that owns YouTube okay fine
that's different from the government
censoring people which is a separate
issue but even that I would still tell
say to Google / alphabet you know you
should be careful about going down that
pathway of censorship
you know you start with something
reasonable like we don't want to let
Isis groups have a YouTube page so that
they can produce recruitment videos okay
that seems pretty simple but then you
get someone like David Icke you know
who's just kind of a fringe goofball
with crazy ideas much like when Joe
Rogan had Alex Jones on you know people
made the same thing now he did not get
that did not get censored by YouTube
this was before YouTube started down
that path a few months ago but
nevertheless I find it very entertaining
it was enjoyable to listen to Alex Jones
get a murd drinking whiskey and smoking
pot with Joe Rogan and and and going off
on his you know multi-dimensional alien
beans in in this case they live in
Silicon Valley and other you know I mean
it does anybody really take him
seriously
some people do yes but hardly anybody
you know there's always been many
comedians Michael believe me this
plaintive weed smoke okay well but I
don't think they're likely to blow up
towers or whatever oh then no one you
organized enough believe you me no yeah
so again I mean I get the temptation
it's there you know let's shut these
people down and and I will admit I kind
of felt that same way when Alex Jones
his followers started showing up at the
parents of Sandy Hook shooting victims
you know that's that's really bad when
they do that but again you know there's
there's some element of moral
culpability on the people that do it not
on Alex Jones's crazy ideas you know
people do act on their ideas but it's
the people acting that should be held
accountable and responsible not the
person that other the speech in my
opinion woody where do you stand Michael
on the you know we've got these big tech
companies I mean they're not think
that's the wrong word they are
essentially monopolies and they get to
choose what goes on their platform what
doesn't will gets broadcast to you know
hundreds of millions of people do you
think they're too big too powerful or do
you think they're probably companies
they can put on whatever they want it's
not really an issue you
really the ladder because era of
monopolies has always been around since
corporations are in thereand
and I mean regulate them or break them
up and they have it in some case with
antitrust laws in the United States but
as the men is competition that is to say
we just need more platforms and there
are there are people developing more
alternative platforms you know and and I
think the same thing will happen with
search engines with the equivalent of
YouTube you know other platforms to post
videos you know as we've seen now
already quickly in the last few months
just a competition for streaming
services for movies you know Hulu and
Netflix and Amazon Prime and Disney plus
and now ABC NBC CBS are all launching
their own streaming platforms so this is
the solution to to monopolies is to
break them up by competition not by Fiat
from the government in my opinion that's
that that's a better way to deal with it
I wrote about this in my book and the
mind of the market about the the lawsuit
against Microsoft for bundling Netscape
and and sort of forcing people to use
Netscape well by the time
internet Laura it yeah Internet Explorer
yes sorry yeah neither of them Michael
that but by the time that loss who went
through the ports and on appeal and year
it was I don't was years and years a
drug on no one was using those
technologies anymore right and that's
the solution just keep you know more
innovation you know more inventions more
competition between people you know it
is a it is a concern although we see
this in politics we essentially have a
duopoly in the United States the
Democrats and Republicans capture 99
percent of everything all the money all
the votes and so on and it would be
better if we were more like European
countries that had you know four or five
viable parties that that would be good
at competition and but the plate
tim is rig but it's designed here in the
United States Pam and but the very
league would be good to have you know
some tech billionaire like a Peter teal
launched a new platform to compete with
YouTube you know and I think he sits on
the board of Google or something like
that so maybe do that but you know
somebody like that you know or a Jeff
Bezos you know maybe longing something
like a YouTube for with next to Amazon
crime video something like that I think
well that's an interesting point and you
bring up the political side of all this
and here's what some people might say to
the argument you've just made which is
that even when you have you know
different platforms they all based in
Silicon Valley they're all run by woke
liberals right people that are perceived
as being work liberals they they don't
necessarily act a particularly work anti
capitalist in terms of their business
practices good but in terms of their in
terms of their policies on you know
restrictions in terms of their pushing
of diversity in the way that it's now
defined in all of those respects
Facebook Google Instagram owned by
Facebook you know YouTube owned by
Google the power is consolidated into
the hands of five or six people who all
think the same who when they make a
decision about let's say banning
somebody off their platform there's no
question that they collude with each
other because those people get banned
simultaneously across the different
platforms so even if you have another
search engine it's likely to be based in
in California it's likely to be run by
the same types of people and then the
political the political shenanigans that
you then get as a result of that kind of
mindset being the only one that's
involved is that you end up in a
position where even if you have three
different YouTube like alternatives they
still all find David Icke yeah that's
right that's possibility but we saw this
you know when the rise of television in
the 60s and 70s there were just the
three here in the United States just the
three major networks and PBS you know
the government run
you know competition as it were is a
little more independent but now you know
we have you know 500 channels and just
endless content available in endless
news sources and so on you know there
was sort of a consolidation of news
media with just a handful of newspapers
Wall Street Journal New York Times here
and the CBS NBC ABC on television but
now you know there's you know 10,000
sources of news and and of course we're
about that oh it's like well wait a
minute you want to get rid of a lot of
those because they're so fringy and they
pass around fake news but before you
were complaint there were only three
sources so what's the number you know is
it 16 is it 27 is it 245 what's the
right number of sources and the answer
is just let the market decide that let
people choose get people some some
accountability for making their own
choices and you know let's let's let's
address it that way you know watch out
for being in a in a bubble in which
you're only reading people that agree
with you oh you know try reading
somebody else that disagrees with you
you know but you can't force people to
do that because they're they're not
likely to accept the content you're
forcing them forcing upon them so you
have to make it a free choice and I just
think more competition and more
availability sources is better Michael
what is your position on the firt so for
instance I'm more to the left than you
are and I'm less libertarian and I have
a more tonight shall I say distrust of
the markets and I'm like well if we just
leave it to the markets to decide then
what you're going to get is a Google
that just is so big it's so powerful it
just swallows up all its competitors and
that's gonna be our only option yeah
yeah well that's what they said about GM
and and IBM and I remember an interview
with Bill Gates and I think T 96-97
where they asked him what do you fear
the most and he said I fear I mean they
say are you worried about IBM or this is
I fear that there's a couple of guys in
a garage
or coming up with something I can't
think of and then you know two years
later Google is launched by you know a
couple guys in a garage and and that
that's always the possibility and to me
the answer to the fear of monopolistic
power of a single corporation somebody
like a Jeff Bezos can stand up to a
Google I mean he has the capability and
the resources to do that by the way you
know am now now Amazon is a target
everybody's afraid that Amazon's gonna
you know destroy all retail and there'll
be no more retail stores and so on
that's the talk right now well first of
all you know the service he's provided
is is pretty valuable in a pandemic I
mean they're you know he's hired several
hundred thousand new people so that's
good for jobs and he's delivering
products right to your doorstep so you
don't have to go out with your mask or
possibly contaminated so that's good for
society and the pandemic and he's making
money doing it but but it's only in the
last couple years at Emma's thought
Amazon started making money you know for
20 years they were kind of kind of
hovering on bankruptcy you know
constantly borrowing money and so on and
and Elon is still in the same position
with Tesla you know they could still go
belly-up he's always you know scrambling
for more investments monies and and you
know I don't know how these billionaires
move digits around on the computer
screen and and you know to me it's a
it's a whole nother world that I'm not
familiar with but but I see what they're
doing but they're the ones taking the
risk to do that and also it's good to
remember you know when when we pick
targets like Google Amazon you know
Steve Jobs Jeff Bezos Bill Gates we're
we're subject there to the availability
heuristic and the survival bias the
survival biases the people that made it
what about all the people that you know
that risked all of their investments all
their savings they borrowed money from
their family banks from venture
capitalists and they went belly-up they
went bankrupt that's what happens to
most entrepreneurial efforts they mostly
fail I have a venture capitalist friend
who gives me sort of a back in the
envelope calculation
for every hundred pigeons they here they
fund one for every hundred companies
they fund one makes it to an IPO where
the head guy is a billionaire you know
so in other words you know one out of a
hundred and one out of a hundred what
happened to the other you know 99.9%
they all win the either went bankrupt or
they're just bear struggling along it's
like you walk you know those business
book stalls at the airport and it's all
these books about the successful people
in business what about all the ones that
went bankrupt and they went out of
business no one writes biographies of
them you can read Michael is when the
Steve Jobs biography came out it's a
great read and he's a fascinating
character but it was okay let's let's
let's scroll through this thing and see
what what the secret sauce is okay so
you go to an elite college you drop out
you move back to parents house you start
a company in your garage you act like a
complete [ __ ] you treat your
employees like [ __ ] and then you get to
be a success a super successful person
no no that's not the formula no happened
to work for him but this is the survival
bias we have a only noticing that
particular instance so you know for
every Jeff Bezos there's you know a
hundred like him that we never heard of
as they never succeeded they failed and
so we have to allow the possibility of
super success by one company one person
because we're not supporting we're not
gonna back the people that failed and
bail them out because that's just the
risk that they take and we're willing to
allow that and I suppose again coming
from a question from the left what would
you say if these companies you know like
your Jeff Bezos you know you like your
Amazon's like your apples you know when
it comes to things like workers rights
when it comes to that and the fact that
you've got these large companies
effectively not treating you know
employees like they should surely if
there was greater competition for people
to go and work with different companies
they wouldn't be allowed to get away
with it well to that I would say
compared to what you know the the
workers rights revolutions been around
for a century and workers rights has
banded throughout the 20th century
giving them more and more rights and you
know unions is one solution to that it's
not a big fan of unions but you know
they are effective tool against
management and they did earn a lot of
workers rights and in any case as I
mentioned before you know the government
regulatory state is pretty powerful you
know there's a lot of things Bezos can't
do to his employees and they can't
complain and they have been and
government local government state
governments have been going in to
investigate like okay what's the deal
here how are you treating these people
that they don't get breaks they have to
work you have 12 hours instead of 8
hours what's going on here and there's
already laws about that so it's really
just a matter of enforcement of the laws
that are already on the books which are
pretty extensive um and there's a bevy
of lawyers looking for work companies
like that that have deep pockets when
they violate workers right it's so all
that's already in place and taking place
I'm terribly worried about that all
right Michael well let's change the
subject a little bit you spend your
whole life debunking myths and
inaccuracies pseudo-scientific claims
and now I think we've never lived in an
era where the term fake news has been
used quite as ubiquitously as it has
been and frankly when the fake news
hasn't been as ubiquitous as is now at
least I would suggest that's the case
you know what would you make of the
political landscape
obviously in America you've probably got
the election still coming up and despite
the the lockdown we had this similar
election very recently here in the UK
where now it's almost like par for the
course that whichever side loses claims
that it only happened because of fake
news or because of in our case there was
some message on a bus that was
inaccurate and that's why everyone voted
from brakes air and you know etc etc so
are we descending into this kind of
political conversation which is no
longer conversation is just people
throwing out fake stuff and then the
other
side going everything the other side is
fake is that the direction we're going
in by the way let me let me ask you if
you'd happen to know this is is it that
the number one search after brexit was
what is brexit by people in england
what is entropy in union yeah that's
pretty crazy if it's true well okay
there's there's some just on that point
actually let me say because it's an
issue we've explored quite a bit and i
think our viewers would want me to
interject that in some ways brexit was
not so much about leaving the european
union and it's a long and complicated
conversation but to a lot of people it
was about a loss of national identity it
was about controlling immigration so
people felt rightly or wrongly by the
way but they felt that leaving the EU
was about that and also about as we say
in the UK sticking two fingers up to the
establishment was really a rejection of
business as usual let's just carry on in
some ways Donald Trump was very similar
but please go ahead no I agree with that
I think that's right the rise of
populism nationalism kind of
authoritarian leaning governments I mean
there are still authoritarian regimes
but at UK in the United States are not
that far but but you know stick it to
the man kind of pushback I agree that
that's probably what it's about
so you again people don't have to know
anything about what brexit really means
or what the trade deals are gonna be and
how how the pricing is gonna work for
bananas listen there's something about
the EU regulating the cure of bananas or
something like that and the and the UK
people are going back off holy -
whatever bananas we want you're
rehashing some of the painful moments of
the campaign yeah I will recount some
research by Hugo Mercier a cognitive
scientist Brendon me and a few other
political scientists since the 2016
election and their conclusion is that
the fake news business the so-called
Russian
hacking that the Internet bubbles
Facebook bubbles and so on had very
little effect on the election that is to
say back to my Hilary and the pizzeria
feel pedophilia ring you know people
that believe that you know are not not
going to suddenly vote for Hillary when
I show them that that at conspiracy
theory is fake they they already hate
Hillary right so most people are not
nudged one way or the other by some
particular story on some fringe internet
website instead we're pretty predictably
tribal and going to you know vote one
direction or the other you know Hugo
mercy he actually thinks political
advertising is almost a complete waste
of money in time that it has next to no
effect and and if so that would be
interesting because of the you know
billions of dollars spent in advertising
before an election probably has very
little effect and I think there's pretty
good evidence for that
so whether these sites are allowed or
not I think is probably irrelevant based
on the research we have that you know
fake news has always been around I mean
it's just more prevalent now because
we're a we're talking about it and B
there's more you know real time almost
instant sources for news so it feels
like it's more pervasive but it looks
like it's far less influential than we
initially thought in 2016-2017 and by
the way with the Russian so-called
Russian hacking again it it probably had
little effect on the election in any
case let's not forget we've done that
kind of thing before you know there's
you know you know stories about the CIA
a messing around in elections in South
American countries in which we were
supporting fascist dictatorships over
communist dictatorships because at least
the fascists are more supportive of you
know American business interests because
they can gain on it that are whereas
opposed the Communists are going to
naturalize these corporations and that's
no good for American business so you
know we were we were providing money and
weapons and so on to you know that the
dictatorship was called you know he's a
son of a [ __ ] but he's our son of a
[ __ ] right so that kind of thing has
always gone on and you know improbable
about with the media but let's not
forget I'm old enough to remember Nixon
Nixon hated the media and you know in
those private conversations he recorded
that came out in the 90s after he was
dead about you know what he said about
Jews rounding the medians that was like
holy crap this guy's a real anti-semite
you know Trump is bad Nixon was probably
just as bad but we didn't you know we
didn't have access you know like Nixon
wasn't tweeting every twenty minutes
so I doesn't seem it didn't seem as bad
at the time that's really interesting I
mean as a Russian first of all I have to
say take deep offense at the suggestion
we were not competent in what we were
doing actually of course I was someone
who initially thought that Russia had
had hacked the election blah blah blah
but the evidence just isn't there but
it's interesting that you talk about
political I admit what evidence isn't
there I mean we we know they were they
tried but they didn't they don't really
succeed and and there's no collusion
with Donald Trump and so there's no
question that almost probably every
single government in the world tries to
influence the American elections because
it's what determines their future in
every single road right so look that's
unquestionable the Chinese probably did
more of it than the Russians we know the
China runs a lot of congressional races
and all that but anyway let's let's not
get stuck in too much into that you
mentioned political advertising I would
put it to you the function of political
advertising at this point is not about
changing hearts and minds it's about
antagonizing your own base to go out
into your world and get the boat out you
get the vote out number one but also if
it's true then isn't what we're doing
here completely pointless Michael which
is having a conversation across you know
Francis's on the Left I'm in the center
you are you know free libertarian from
what I know right so what's the point I
mean if we're not convincing anyone if
we just we is this kind of mental
masturbation just for us or it or is
that actually any point to what we're
doing there's probably a joke a comedian
could come up with that but yes well
again the
point of free speech is to have
conversations so that peak and listen
and reason themselves particular
decision now you know which way you vote
is maybe a separate issue from a hundred
other things we might think about and
talk about you know abortion immigration
gun control you know that the you know
vaccines versus the anti-vaxxers you
know the Holocaust and uh creationism
and there's a you know a thousand topics
we could talk about and most of them
most people haven't thought that
carefully through so you know we're in
other words are sort of after the
undecided voter and maybe not in a
political parties in life in general and
you know there's this mean that was
going around years ago that you can't
reason somebody out of a belief that
they didn't reason their way to in the
first place but that's not true I know
from just personal experience emails I
get every day people I'd changed my mind
about this is that after I read your
book or you read your article or you
made me think or whatnot that it is true
that facts can matter again back to the
cognitive research on this cognitive
science research that if you present
data in a way in a in a particular way
people are more receptive to it if it's
visual
you know pie graphs and bar graphs and
so on people can grasp it instantly if
you just put up a chart of you know
numbers you know it's just a mind just
the eyes is glazed over and and but but
more importantly you have to present it
in a way that doesn't force people that
have to give up some particularly deep
core belief that they hold so for
example the analogy I use of you know
Beckett my debating creationist be give
people Choice between Darwin and Jesus
you know they're not picking Darwin
right a Christian accepts Jesus as his
Savior that's the most important thing
in his life all right so what does he
care about this Darwin guy but if you if
you present it like you know evolution
may be the way God created life and the
diversity of life this was God's method
and then then it takes that off the
table like okay so what's this theory
all about right same thing with climate
denial I I you know unfortunately or
fortunately you know Al Gore's success
with his
inconvenient truth affiliated climate
science with the left is a that's a
that's a liberal cause therefore I is a
conservative have to be against that and
that put it you know took it off the
scientific table and put it into the
political arena which polarized it so I
I just basically take that off the table
by saying something like you know it's
not a liberal cause it's just it's
either true or not and by the way you
can make a ton of money in green
technology and capitalism can save the
day of global warming
people like Elon Musk creating electric
cars or something now you know
conservatives they like to hear that so
then they're like okay so what's this
climate science thing anyway because you
know the studies since in the last
minute we five years or so show that
knowledge about climate science is not a
predictor of whether you accept it or
not and and and unfortunately just the
way it is you know people that accept
climate science don't seem to know any
more about it than people that deny
climate science
so having scientific knowledge by itself
is not a predictor of whether you accept
it or not so when people are commenting
say on social media about their position
on climate science they're actually just
virtue signaling to their fellow tribal
members now I'm a conservative side
outed or I'm a liberal and I accept it
so you have to get a you have to go
around that to invent convince people
and then present the data in a pre
accessible way and it's very interesting
that you say that because it's quite
depressing that everything has now
become these binary terms like you know
like you just said and it's all
political all the rest of it I think a
lot of this and you've said so it your
book comes from campus it comes from the
culture wars which have started on
campus do you think that the
coronaviruses is going to be almost a
bomb to that because people are going to
real nice you know what we're all in
this together it doesn't matter if you
left me all right the virus you can
affect anyone it may help us to kind of
come together and listen to each other
more I'm I've been smoking too much of
the health I thought exactly that until
maybe just two weeks ago
when you know the sort of bitter
fighting returned to normal here least
in the United States and you know it
would be nice to think you know like
that like the old sci-fi scenario you
know if the earth got invaded by aliens
you know we'd all you know it'd become
united as one species against this
common enemy and in essence that's what
the cove in my team is is is a enemy and
it looked like was going to do that I
think there's still some signs that you
know people are most people are pretty
good about that about this but you know
we're kind of starting the return to our
old tribal ways of you know not just
disagreeing with other people but hating
them you know that they're not just
wrong they're immoral they're bad
they're evil you know there's a lot of
that unfortunately our president here is
you know kind of fuels that he feels is
based he has you know eighty million
followers on Twitter and you know boy
it's it I am worried about that I wish
we would be more more commonly unite
hello that that could still happen we'll
see students just soon to tell you know
you mentioned they actually the Academy
I'm a professor at Chapman University
they're you know they're really worried
if you know students don't return in the
fall they're not gonna pay fifty
thousand bucks a year to hear me
yammering away at a in this particular
garage and you know they pay that kind
of money to go to a brick-and-mortar
school where there's professors and and
and and sororities and fraternities and
a social life and gyms and you know it's
a whole package so this this could
change the Academy it's hard to say what
direction I think that the simple
transfer of knowledge from one school to
another that couldn't be done remotely
simply cheaply you know the if you look
at the economics of the rising cost of
colleges over the last say fifty years
compared to any other basket of goods
that have also gone up you know but a
quart of milk or a gallon of gas loaf of
bread whatever you know they've all gone
up of course you adjust for inflation
and whatnot but college tuition is just
skyrocketed and and yet the ratio of
professors to students is roughly about
the same what's changed is the
administrative structure has just
expanded wildly I mean there's you know
way more employees at universities that
don't teach at all what are they doing
okay well it may be that universities
and colleges will have to look into that
more and say maybe we don't need this
Dean at diversity here because you know
how is that students don't pay for that
students the parents now parents might
start asking questions about that with
this generation I think that would be
the number one priority
so it seems and obviously one of the
things that we've talked to a lot of
people about in the past but with the
rising tuition fees there's also a rise
in student expectation in terms of their
power and influence and the ability to
say well this is how things should be at
my university this is you know I am
demanding that this person so I don't
like does not speak on my camp you know
I'm demanding this on demanding that so
do you think that that much we might
start to see a cultural shift simply as
a result of the fact that universities
are gonna have to rethink their model a
little bit yeah I think that's entirely
possible you know my friend and
colleague John confident Heights and
Greg lukianov wrote that book the
coddling of the American mind right but
yeah so they you know their hypothesis
is you know twofold that that got a
culture of safety is omim that that
arose in the 80s and kind of solidified
in the 90s that today's college kids
that that's when they were born ninety
six and after the so-called I generally
they're they started coming into college
in around twenty fourteen or so and
that's when we saw the rise of kind of
demanding a culture of the college's to
be more like parents and you know to
protect them your your job is to provide
a safe home for us here at this College
and you know no that is not their job
that hasn't been their job in 50 years
in fact the whole point of the 60s
revolution was to overthrow
that idea of in loco parentis you know
that that parents sent their kids off to
college the college administrators and
professors treated them like they they
were their children and the 60s was you
know in a way a revolution was to say
we're adults we're gonna you know smoke
pot we're gonna you know drugs and rock
and roll baby so leave us alone so this
is kind of a weird reversal of what you
know took place in that with the sexual
Roshan and the 60s and all that now
we've kind of going back to the 50s like
you know it's your job to protect this
what and you know and that gets wrapped
up into this you know back to my book
that this is sort of a weird fitting I
have to write this defense of free
speech you know because a man I'm very
liberal you know probably far left on
free speech at least what used to be
liberal right now far-right way your
life you believe in free speech as we
all know that's right I mean
conservatives you know when I see people
like Sean Hannity on Fox News defending
free speech I'm like oh my god this guy
you know and you see these liberals uh
that you know he's a marine you know
defending censorship it's like this is a
completely backward you man
remember when conservatives were up in
arms about rock lyrics you know and
Frank Zappa was defending free speech
and you know Madonna is defending free
speech and and they're trying to censor
her videos and you know and all that
what happened to that you know that's
kind of that's what I'm writing about
maybe I'm a conservative I'm in favor of
censoring Madonna songs but anyway okay
no I make that makes you a Russian
you're in favor of censoring women now
wouldn't you say the case so Michael is
look we complain the kids all we want
but as a former teacher and your
university professor the parents have
got to take the box for this Shirley
they've raised these kids so they have
to take responsibility that they've
raised the mollycoddle children yeah I
agree
yeah but you know when you're adult you
still have some responsibility and more
ability I do believe in free will at
least a form of free will in which you
some accountability for your actions so
I put some of it on the students but
yeah the parents and but but we need it
a little deeper it's like at the crime
wave that started in the 60s and peaked
and started going back down in 1993 you
know that the parents have k then and
we're you know super tops and careful
and worried and scared
I remember the milk carton kids you know
that the picture of the little kid on
the side of a milk carton you know it
was kidnapped mmm you know and it wasn't
till later that you know the
criminologists and statisticians
pointing it out that you know 99% of
kidnappings are by one of the parents in
a divorce dispute in a custody dispute
so you know letting your little Johnny
or Mary you know walk down the block to
the playground they're not gonna get
kidnapped unless you're going through a
custody dispute with your spouse right
that culture safety of the ism was
probably overblown you know I now have a
four year old I have a 29 year old and a
four year old my four year old now
taking him to playgrounds these
playgrounds are designed by lawyers I
mean they're just like super pad and
extra careful and nothing can go wrong
it's like wow what happened and it's
that culture to safety ISM you know that
we can't know how anybody hurt the
according to Jonathan hi Frankie on off
anyway in their book that's one
explanation the other there are other
hypotheses by the way screen time not
not just television but but more focused
social media is screen time seems to
affect kids more girls both ways maybe
double the rate of anxiety depression
you know the cancel culture is very
destructive and I mean I kind of get a
glimpse of that I'm and I'm an okay
boomer you know I'm 65 so I don't I
don't worry I don't do a lot of social
media but I can feel it like you know I
have a book come out and get you know
positive review positive reviews super
positive comments and then one pops up
that you you know that's super negative
and I'm like oh my god and I can't
that's all I can focus on is this guy
this is just [ __ ] [ __ ] said this
about me I'm gonna get just like calm
down Shermer yeah
multiply that by you know a hundred
every day every hour these kids you know
reading social media you know they the
negativity bias you know we're we're
losses for twice as much as gains feel
good you know negative comments are
twice as potent as positive come are
rewarding so it's like oh boy now so you
know the some are calling for that
regulation so much as recommendations to
parents you know maybe you should allow
your kid on a screen two hours a day or
three hours a day has yet to be worked
out because the data is still coming in
and what's the right number you know but
surely there's some balance between your
kid run out go outside and run with
other kids at playgrounds and get some
sunshine and buy to a vitamin D is
supposed to be good for club in nineteen
so the verse is sitting in the you know
back room on the screen there's some
balance there yeah for sure well Michael
listen it's a great book and we
recommend everybody gets it and reads it
given the devil his due
tell everybody is it out already or did
we get yeah it's published by a
Cambridge University Press so it's out
it was out in England first and then in
the United States so and it's available
everywhere unfortunately I'll book most
bookstores have been closed with my book
so that was unfortunate but but whereas
Amazon back to Amazon and Amazon's not
the only one that deliver you can
actually also go to skeptic calm and
order a signed God because I went back
to my office and sign hundreds of copies
so we had them available well if you
want to sign copy with Michaels personal
coronavirus on it make sure you go to
the don't give Jeff money that's what
you want but Michael thank you so much
for coming on the show before
thanks for having me you guys you guys
are a lot of fun and it's good to be
pushed a little bit well there is more
for you on that front because we've got
one more question for you okay I'm the
question that we always end our shows
with Michael is what's the one thing
we're not talking about as a society
that we really should be yeah well I
would say it's talking about talking
that we should be talking about letting
other people
especially people you don't like because
they may be right
partially right completely right you
might be partially wrong completely
wrong in any case it's it's good to have
your position challenged because if
nothing else it strengthens your own
position I hear what you're saying but
I'm not gonna stop interrupting Francis
on that no Michael thank you so much and
thank you Gary while watching we'll see
you all very soon with another brilliant
interview or a live stream thanks for
watching guys as always subscribe to the
YouTube channel click the bell button
next to subscribe button so you get
notified when a video comes out and
follow us on all the social media at
trigger pod and also leave us a nice
review on iTunes and spread the word